[Music]
the most common pattern that I've seen
after interviewing hundreds 300 400 500
world-class performers at this point is
that at least 80% have some type of
mindfulness or meditation practice and
if you are like me perhaps you've heard
of this many times and perhaps you even
tried many times and decided you do not
meditate you cannot meditate you are not
designed to meditate which is what I
concluded for a very very long time
until I tested a number of simple
options that may work for you and I
would anticipate that really one or two
will stick and have some type of toehold
and you'll be able to then develop the
habit over a week or two of doing this
and I recommend trying it first thing in
the morning here are a few different
options
number one is using an app of some type
and there are several that are well
designed headspace would be one the ten
in ten that's ten minutes per day for 10
days straight is very effective calm is
another insight timer is yet another
there are many on top of that if you
want to go straight to guided
meditations you could consider looking
for Sam Harris you can consider looking
for Tara brach pra CH there are many
different options and they range in
length so you can choose something that
works for you
next option is something like
Transcendental Meditation
where you actually take a course and you
have that social accountability and you
pay for it and then you will work with
someone for four days straight
you will meditate in between those
sessions and you will need to report
back to them and it is 20 minutes per
day twice per day encouraged most people
at least I do it once per day normally
in the morning that is mantra based
meditation another option is picking one
song that is very uplifting to you like
we're gonna party like it's 1999 by
Prince which is the one I actually use
in the early days and you simply listen
to that song first thing in the morning
and focus on your breath and you want to
sit in a comfortable position so I would
sit cross-legged with my back against a
wall you certainly sit in a chair you
could sit with your feet
the ground hands on your thighs it
doesn't matter you want it to be
comfortable listen to this song focus on
your breath
and when you focus on your breath this
is very common advice what does that
mean alright we should get specific so a
few recommendations you could focus
certainly on feeling it in your lower
abdomen you can focus on feeling at your
chest what a lot of people find helpful
is actually focusing on feeling the
breath the inhale and exhale right on
the edges of their nostrils and you
might even notice that on the inhale
it's cooler and on the exhale it's
warmer all right those are two tips that
I find very very helpful and the last
recommendation I would make is actually
twofold so there are two super short
options throughout the day if you find
yourself feeling stressed out or anxious
or if you're about to say something you
might regret take a three breath break
this is actually something I started
doing I had heard 10 breaths that seemed
excessive to me which I know is funny
but I would pause to just focus on
taking three deep breaths that is a form
of meditation and mindfulness present
state awareness training the other is
something called loving-kindness
meditation or Metta a meet ETA
meditation and this is very simple
instead of focusing on yourself you're
going to focus on other people this was
a breakthrough for me and actually made
a big difference in my entire experience
in practicing meditation
and really all you're gonna do is sit
down
eyes closed comfortably and focus on
envisioning someone you care for that's
where you start a friend family member
whoever it might be and wishing them joy
and happiness you can do that any way
you want all right you're wishing them a
joy and happiness and a life free of
pain and suffering and you do that for
one or two minutes for one person then
you do it for one or two minutes for the
next and I have seen multiple friends
try this and they do it for five minutes
either first thing in the morning or
right before going to bed and at the end
of the week they tell me that is the
best week I've had in years all right so
that's another option that you can test
out so those are whatever it is six
seven eight different options try them
all you could try one a day for a week
find one that sticks and the imperfect
program the good program that you follow
is better than the perfect
you don't follow so pick something
simple get started and you can always
add to it later
you